Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
In the book of fasting of
we are in the chapters regarding what is
preferred
and you know must for someone to do when
they are fasting.
[Silence]
One of the things that
is
a very important sunnah and is actually
something that is not only the sunnah of
our prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
But specifically differentiates us from
other nations and their fasting is that
we hasten
to break our fast.
Hasten to break our fast. Meaning we
break our fast as soon as it is
permissible. the closest we can to when
the sun sets.
[Silence]
Abu is
he says on the authority of
that the messenger of Allah
said people
will always be in a state of good
standing
as long as they are hastening the
breaking of their fast. What does this
mean?
People will always be in good standing.
Meaning that people will be upon the way
of the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam. They will not have strayed
so far in fasting from the sunnah of
their messenger.
See if you imagine with me how many
billions of Muslims have come between us
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. If
you imagine all of these billions of
people are, if we break them down, they
are individuals
and human beings naturally have a
creative bent to them.
And so if each person wanted to
create, wanted to add something to Islam
from himself, wanted to take away
something from Islam from himself
to, you know, I think this is good. I
should do this. I'd to do this. I
this. This feels right. This feels
good.
Now, if everyone were to exercise that
and we didn't have scholars to put us
right back on the path and show the path
and constantly illuminate and point out
where the path is with respect to where
we are, if we were to imagine each
person was able to add or subtract from
this religion as he desired, just one
thing, one word, one letter.
Islam would never have reached us by
now. It would have been so
absolutely distorted and changed and
rearranged that it would be
unrecognizable.
And so this process of innovation is
what occurred with the previous nations.
If we were to take modern day modern day
Christian and compare him to and and
have him meet
the ancient Christian that was one
generation after Isaam
and have them sit down and have a
conversation about their beliefs. How
incredibly radically different would not
only their their beliefs but their core
beliefs be meaning with respect to the
nature of IsaB with respect to the
worship of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala the
names and attributes of Allah how
radically different would they be and
the reason for this is
well there are a couple of reasons, but
one of the main reasons is the
scholarship. Scholarship of previous
nations is not the scholarship of
our nation. And
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam is
telling us here that people will be in
good standing. Meaning with respect to
their proximity from the path that they
are upon that sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasam as long as they are
hastening to break their fast.
The Jews even in the time of the
companions
would only break their fast
when the they would see the stars
in the sky clearly
and uninterrupted
across the sky and across the horizons.
This is when they would break their
fast. That would be way late, closer to
than it is to right.
And also
they would start their fast much
earlier. the Muslim. We start our fast
as close to as possible and we break our
fast as immediately
after as possible.
And a person breaking his fast and
hastening the breaking of his fast does
not necessitate that a person would
hence delay making
on account of breaking his fast.
[Silence]
He said, "And the correct way with
respect to breaking one's fast and
eating a full meal after breaking your
fast is that a person would break his
fast as immediately
as possible at the heels of
sunset.
And upon doing so person would break his
fast with one of the things that are
mentioned in the sunnah which we will
get to in the next point and then make
salah and then a person goes and eats at
his leisure right basically what we do
what we do here at the masid what most
people do
al
Another sunnah, another etiquette of
fasting.
[Silence]
narrates that the messenger of Allaham
would most usually break his fast on
fresh dates, fresh dates, dates that
have not been dried.
And if fresh dates were unavailable,
then on dried dates, dried dates, what
comes to your mind when I say dates?
Those are dried dates. Fresh dates are
well, we know what fresh dates look
right? They're they're
they're soft and they're
[Arabic recitation]
Huh?
Bella. Yeah, we call them Bella. We call
them bell. So it's, you know what I'm
talking about. And so
those fresh dates. And if not, then
dried dates.
And if there are no dried dates
available, then he would drink a few
gulps of water. Sai wasallam. And you
know this is his sunnah.
you know when a person has been fasting
all day and they become really hungry
usually that hunger
what is driving it mostly is the need
for sugar right that's why you want to
break your fast and have yourself a big
Snickers bar or have yourself a the
reason for that is body's running low on
that and so dates are very prime for
that.
However, those are real good sugars.
They're not you know, the kind
of processed things that we get or water
to prepare the stomach, prepare the body
for
you know to get the digestive system
up and running and ready to go. person
makes and then they're able to eat and
[Arabic recitation]
He said another etiquette of fasting is
that a person upon breaking his fast
is to say the dua the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam used to say when he
would break his fast. Omar narrates and
the narration is in
that the messenger of Allah. Wasam upon
breaking his fast would say,
meaning the thirst has been quenched
and the veins have been quenched
inshallah and the reward has been
affirmed and written inshallah. There
are other
ini
and elsewhere in the books of hadith,
books of sunnah with respect to other
dua that a person would make upon
breaking his fast. All of them are weak
narrations or very weak narrations. The
only narration that has an authentic
chain of narration free of any
imperfections or weaknesses is this
chain of narration.
Inshallah. This is what the prophetam
was known to most prominently make dua
upon breaking his fast.
tomorrow inshallah we will discuss
what is permissible what is mub for a
person to do when he is fasting.
things showering rinsing out
one's mouth
etc. And then we will discuss
and the etiquets of inshallah
you know to get ready for
so
[Silence]
alhamdulillah. for